it's a pretty big deal for a lot of
people that sell stuff on the internet
um you know Google is the elephant uh in
the game maybe the empathy elephant be
friends anyway
um
this trend of how people are getting
information not just through Google
anymore but with Tick Tock and Reddit
and Instagram is not on here but so many
of you watching this search on Instagram
and now with AI coming
the landscape's changing and for a lot
of people they've relied on being good
at SEO sem search optimization or paying
uh toll booths Affiliates or aggregators
to get them their business
and they haven't been building brand on
social creating awareness making people
look for their stuff instead of going to
a search engine and searching generic
and AI voice things like hey Alexa send
me some clothes all this leads to if
you're not building brand and they can't
have it in their top of the mind or top
of the tongue you might be in trouble in
the next decade